so speaking as a less famous non-binary
resident of vermont
yeah this thing has layers in how it
annoys me
[Music]
all right well
i did say towards the start of the year
i had a feeling that this kind of
content me doing a relatively quick
turnaround talking about nonsense going
on with individuals that impacts the
sorts of things i normally talk about
was probably going to happen regularly i
really wish i'd been wrong
but we need to talk about ezra miller
here's the first thing i want to lay out
i will be talking about
the ways in which they have gotten in
trouble i will be going over that as
completely as i can i don't think unless
something
really insane happens i don't think i'm
going to have any addendums on this one
though
because
i actually don't care if anything new
happens with them between when i record
this and when it goes up because what i
mainly want to focus on
is the situation that warner brothers
now finds themselves in as a result of
all this that's usually what i like to
focus on when i talk about these sorts
of things but we need to go over
recent history uh with ezra miller
but before we get to what happened most
recently
it should be noted this is uh far from
uh their first brush with legal issues
it actually goes all the way back to
2011 where they initially had a run-in
with police in regards to marijuana
possession and disorderly conduct i
don't think too many people are holding
that against them any longer because
well it was over a decade ago and it was
pot like nobody cares about pot anymore
so i'm just i'm putting that there for
completeness sake
uh more relevantly in 2020
there was not only an incident
where they
grabbed a woman by the neck and put her
down on the ground in a choke
at a uh bar in reykjavik uh iceland
but that was caught on video i'm not
gonna show it but it's on video
so uh that was sort of where the initial
big concern started to be around like
wait a minute should this person really
be getting positioned as a major
hollywood star and some of the biggest
franchises going if this is how they're
going to behave now
some people did at that point basically
jump ship and either said they weren't
going to watch things with ezra miller
in them or some even going so far as to
say that it's necessary to boycott
things that ezra miller is in to ensure
that they are not uh continued to be
employed
that didn't catch a ton of traction
if i were to guess
i think for people who i'm not sure
anybody thought that was okay what
happened i never really saw anybody make
that argument but well i wouldn't be
surprised if there's a decent percentage
of people who basically were prepared to
let it be a one-off since the last time
they got into any legal trouble was at
that point nine years ago
it
really kind of seemed like okay well
this was at a bar
folks were probably drinking maybe it
was heightened like it's not good
but maybe this is a one-off
well it definitely was not given what's
gone on in the last month so ezra miller
uh has been in hawaii for it's actually
not entirely clear how long they've been
there
but uh things blew up when they were
actually arrested formally arrested by
police in hawaii uh after an incident
where they were screaming again in a bar
screaming obscenities uh yanking the
microphone away from a woman who was
singing karaoke and lunging at a guy
playing darts the police showed up and
did in fact arrest them
now we'll get to the thing that happened
after that but it has recently come out
that this was not a one-off there had
been at least nine previous incidents
of them being in situations and causing
disturbances that resulted in the police
being called there were no arrests made
so it didn't really hit the news cycle
but now it's become background that for
about the last month they have been kind
of terrorizing the hawaiian nightlife
and getting repeatedly thrown out banned
from bars and having the cops called to
show up and ensure that they leave
and then
apparently after being released from the
initial arrest because they weren't
jailed uh as a result of this but being
uh released having the charges filed
they then went to the house that
apparently they were staying at with
this couple and allegedly according to
the couple who has successfully gotten a
temporary restraining order against them
uh they
burst into the bedroom
screamed threats at them and apparently
stole a whole bunch of stuff including a
passport and a wallet
so
i'm not going to dwell too much on these
specific incidents because i'm sure as
heck not going to try and psychoanalyze
and figure out what the hell are they
doing
i don't know
i don't know what's going on and i'm not
going to try and parse it what i want to
talk about what i want to zero in on
is warner brothers
who is
multi-tiered screwed
because of this they're screwed on two
major fronts the first is the third
fantastic beast film
fantastic beasts
uh
secret dumbledore's secret secret of
dumbledore dumbledy bumbledy i don't
know um but then also
next year the flash movie comes out and
of course ezra miller has been playing
the flash in a number of films uh so far
uh well i mean mainly just the two
different versions of justice league and
then recently cameoed in some other
stuff that was dc related not gonna say
what it was because it's a little bit of
a spoiler but
uh
they
really
were lined up to keep things going and
like the flash movie is they this thing
has been in the works forever
and there's potentially depending on
what the story it if it is what is
rumored in terms of the specific like
some things we're pretty certain about
but if the goal and scope of it is what
is expected
they were probably banking on having
ezra miller around for a while
oh boy okay so we're mainly going to be
talking about from the perspective of pr
warner brothers has two major films
coming out
which star in either a major supporting
role or the lead role
an actor who is
now shown a repeated history of violence
that ain't good
now here's the first thing that needs to
be made completely clear and i think
people definitely would have already
figured this out at least with the first
one
warner brothers
uh cannot afford
to remove ezra miller from these films
in the case of fantastic beasts by the
time i get this video out it'll already
have been released in the uk and it'll
be out the following week in the u.s
movies done
they've spent what they're going to
spend on it and they are not gonna
bounce it this close to the release date
over this so whatever pr damage there is
they're just gonna have to eat it and of
course there's already a lot of question
marks and scrutiny around this film
already between the one-two combination
of a crimes of grindelwald not being
especially well received by fans or
critics and the ongoing pr nightmare if
you're trying to appeal to even a
slightly progressive audience of
continuing to support and promote the
works of jk rowling
so like this thing was already in a bit
of trouble and that's before
we even get
to the fact that
while the flat logistical reality
is there was no way there's no time
there is no conceivable way to replace
ezra miller in this film
even if people understand that it's
still a really bad look because they
already replaced another actor for this
film as you may or may not recall back
in 2020 johnny depp was supposed to
take on the role of grindelwald again
replaying it from his initial cameo and
the first film and as a featured
antagonist in the second
that did not happen as and it's worth
pointing this out
strictly speaking he wasn't let go from
that franchise because of the
allegations against him by amber heard
though some of those had actually
already been in the mix when he was in
uh crimes of grindelwald there actually
had been some call that maybe he
shouldn't have been in that film even at
the time at the time warner brothers
stood by him strictly speaking it wasn't
that what it actually was
was that johnny depp lost a lawsuit
that he had brought against um british
tabloids basically
saying like you can't call me a wife
beater was basically what it boiled down
to and he lost that
which means that the reason warner
brothers let him go was strictly from
the pr perspective that if they had him
in place the uk tabloids and keep in
mind even though warner brothers is
primarily an american um studio this is
considered a british uk property
uh
the uk tabloids could have been free if
they so felt to just put
wifebeater's new movie opens up or
anything like that because they'd won in
court the right to be able to call him
that that was the reason he was let go
now yes it's connected to the amber
heard stuff
but strictly speaking he wasn't let go
because of that he was let go because of
the pr issues that resulted from his
lost lawsuit but he got replaced by mads
mikkelsen now warner brothers has
already kind of started looking really
bad around all this as is
because
of the weird complicated and very very
messy stuff that has come out about
amber heard
since then i am not
i am not opening this can of worms any
more than i have to do not turn this
into an argument about johnny depp
versus amber heard just understand
that what at the i'm sure at the time
they made the decision felt like what
made the most sense unfortunately in
another department of warner brothers
over in the dc eu
amber heard was playing mera an aquaman
and is continuing to play the part in
the upcoming aquaman sequel so again
regardless of the actual reality that
johnny depp was more let go because of
the loss of the lawsuit and that the
people at the particular heads of these
different subdivisions the people
working on the harry potter stuff the
people working on the dc comic book
superhero stuff they are not obligated
to
coordinate and hold each other to the
same standard when it comes to who to
retain
the image regardless of all that reality
was that
they booted johnny depp
sided with amber heard
and then at best
the question of depp's guilt or at least
the likelihood of it and or the how
clean uh heard was looking it got again
at best
messy
not getting into it any more than that
but they already kind of had a bad look
on that and now again regardless of the
actual reality being that they can't
reshoot this they're now stuck
with somebody
with violent arrest record
issues
in the film that they booted somebody
from
for a not vastly dissimilar public image
issue
this looks real
real bad
i don't know how badly this is gonna
impact the movie but it's not gonna help
and i can't imagine especially anybody
who might have been on the bubble like
maybe i'll see it maybe i won't
i i don't know how much of a dent this
specific thing is going to take out of
it but it's going to have a little
impact i have a hard time imagining it
wouldn't because at least speaking
personally i know a lot of people who
are were super ambivalent about this
movie even people who continue to
varying degrees to support uh the harry
potter franchise seemed pretty
ambivalent and enthusiastic about this
and this just becomes one more reason to
ah maybe skip it
or wait for streaming or what have you
so uh warner brothers is already
dealing with a massive headache but
theoretically
it's a headache they can ride out
because it will impact the initial
release of the film can't be helped at
this point
they just need to try and power through
and milk as much money out of this
release as they can
but then
there's the flash
which has already been pushed back
well that's not even counting the uh
absolute development hell it's been
going through
so the flash was supposed to come out
this year well actually it was supposed
to come out
in 2020 even before that but like more
recently it was supposed to come out
this year
it got pushed back to 2023 june if i
remember correctly uh mainly because of
the
additional time needed to finish the
special effects this is partly impacted
by kovid and the desire to not have
people crammed together in a tight space
working on all the rendering more people
working from home basically special
effects is a slower process now if you
want to respect the health and the
safety concerns of the people working
for you so they already had to push a
bag a year
now
that might
might
work to their benefit
if
big if
if ezra miller cannot get into any more
trouble between now and then
maybe
it will be in a similar situation to the
choking incident before where
like there was a while that passed
without anything else happening and most
people
like again lots of people weren't but
like the general public seemed to
prepare to let go it was fading from
memory
that is their best case scenario uh
warner brothers best case scenario that
the memory of ezra miller getting
arrested uh fades
because nothing else happens and gives
people reason to keep thinking about it
now that's a big if
uh given like i said this is not really
one incident in hawaii this is a string
of incidents eventually resulting in a
rest and a restraining order
but like this has kind of been going on
continuously for a bit
already
and even if even
if ezra miller does not get in trouble
between now and then warner brothers has
already got to be going oh good because
they are proving themselves to be a
liability
that's the thing it is actually
much less more often than not about the
specific incident that gets a star in
trouble i mean sometimes it's so severe
you just have to walk away and cut them
loose generally what determines whether
or not they continue to be considered to
be employable by hollywood
is how frequently do they keep coming up
in the news cycle for bad behavior
because if it's just the once even if
it's for a pretty bad thing
after a year two years they'll probably
get back to being employed regularly
but when they keep getting in trouble
for similar things over and over and
over again and it keeps coming up in the
public sphere
well that
is the thing that is much more likely to
permanently tank a career and or make a
uh studio not want to work with somebody
anymore and i have to imagine even
taking into account that they cannot
drop them from the flash movie i'll get
into that in a minute even taking that
into account warner brothers has got to
be going we we cannot keep using them
like there might be more films on a
contract but usually those are contract
options not we are definitely giving you
this many movies it's more we can get
this many movies from from you if we
want to keep bringing you back depending
on the specifics of the contract but
that's usually the way it goes and it
plays out so let's talk about why warner
brothers is stuck with them for the
flash movie they're the entire thing
they are
the flash
and i'm sure there are some people out
there who might have been speculating
well this is supposedly kind of a
multiverse movie
why couldn't they replace ezra miller
why couldn't they bring in a flash from
a different universe and just use that
as the opportunity to recast because the
movie's already shot
filming was finished
at this point it's just special effects
work
and you need to realize that to replace
ezra miller
you would most likely have to reshoot
everything that they were in which means
getting back all the resources that you
don't have on hand anymore including
actors set designers costumers the works
you got to get everybody back in and
even if you do the thing with like
tignotaro in army of the dead where you
film the new actor in front of nothing
but green screen which depending on how
effects heavy the movie is might even be
a viable option
that is still going to start so much
work from scratch to reintegrate this
new performer and or to remove
ezra miller from the existing footage
lots of special effects which is already
delaying the film are gonna have to be
redone reworked or possibly done from
scratch off of brand new footage that
had to be shot
you need to realize because of how long
the flash movie has been delayed how
many writers and directors it's already
gone through
they are in a serious sunk cost issue
they've already spent so much money on
this thing
there's already a very very slim chance
that it is ever going to make its money
back as is
they definitely cannot afford
to do this and like keep in mind the
last few times there has been a major
change to an actor in the last few years
shortly before release was the
aforementioned army of the dead with
tygnataro which as i said they had to do
it through all green screen and the
other one was all the money in the world
where kevin spacey was replaced by
christopher plummer now it's worth
noting that in the case of all the money
in the world that added
10 million dollars to what was
originally a 40 million dollar budgeted
film and that movie
that was a low special effects
drama
that did not require the kind of work
organization and post-production that
happens on things like fantastic beasts
and the flash and as far as army of the
dead they did have to do a whole bunch
of green screening in order to get tig
notaro in and replace the original actor
but netflix had a lot of incentive to
pony up for that because they want to
keep zack snyder happy snyder had been
at warner brothers
forever
before things all blew up with justice
league and he left and started working
with netflix netflix even if they don't
make the money back on the reshoots as
far as a raw cost they want to keep
snyder happy because they want him to
stay at netflix and not wander off
somewhere else so it becomes a matter of
look how much we're willing to
accommodate you so they had incentive to
do it and you know what i'll even say
this
if this incident had happened
six months ago
maybe
maybe warner brothers would have ponied
up the money to replace ezra miller in
fantastic beasts they'd already replaced
one actor already it's an effects heavy
movie so maybe depending on the scenes
that they're in it might blend as bad as
well as it's ever going to just to shoot
somebody else in
but again at this point there's no time
and even if they were able to do that
with fantastic beasts
what are you supposed to do with the
flash
it's
too much it would require basically
re-filming the entire movie
from
scratch
and this movie is the rumor at least is
that it's kind of big and important to
the mcu because at this point the mcu
doesn't have a
consistent continuity things aren't
really connecting some things are direct
follow-ups to certain other things as in
batman v superman follows on from man of
steel uh both versions of justice league
follow on from that but you have two
competing versions of justice league
wonder woman seems to fit in with that
but it interacts with it directly so
little doesn't matter ditto aquaman and
then you've got outliers like shazam and
both suicide squad movies now granted
we've had things like peacemaker which
is a direct build off from the suicide
squad but then you've got stuff like the
batman which doesn't slot into the
continuity at all so it's all over the
place now there is word and has been
rumored for a while
and there's some credibility to this
that the flash movie is effectively
going to be the dc equivalent to stephen
strange and the multiverse of madness
interconnecting and bringing in
multiverse aspects now it's actually
arguable dc needed this whereas uh
disney and the mcu probably didn't need
to do this they have chosen to do this
we'll see what they do with it i'm kind
of skeptical about i'm not a big fan of
multiverse stories but setting that
aside dc probably if they wanted to
pretend like there was a plan
needed to do oh and i even forgot about
joker which doesn't slot into anything
either so they if they want to pretend
that there's a plan and any of this
stuff is interconnected they need a
multiverse story to really start dealing
with this stuff and that is supposedly
what this flash movie is going to be and
there is reason to suspect it will in
fact be that based off amongst other
things michael keaton coming back to
reprise his role as batman as in the tim
burton batman from
1989
so there's ample reason to believe that
this is going to be that story now again
you might think well that means that
like multiverse we you get a different
actor in you really can't because as i
said they're in the whole thing
so i cannot imagine warner brothers
ponying up that money especially for a
movie that's already filmed it's done
it's in the can production costs are
done it's all post-production and
marketing now expenses that don't go
away but suddenly you're doubling your
production budget to shoot effectively
the whole movie over again because
i guarantee you even if they try and do
the most cost effective version possible
which is basically the tignatara route
of shooting a new actor on green screen
and cging them into everything that is
still going to take longer and cost more
than they are prepared to shell out on a
movie that it's already questionable if
they were going to make any money back
on here's the one asterix i will put
on this
i would say it's not out of the realm of
possibility
either
if
we see alternate versions of the flash
played by other actors in this or if
that's not already the case possibly do
minor reshoots
to add that in so at the very end of the
film
they can move forward with a different
actor in the role of the flash i
wouldn't rule that out completely
whether or not they
feel it's viable or worth it or whatever
who knows
warner brothers kind of has taken the
approach at this point of every time a
movie isn't what they really want it to
be
or doesn't perform as well as they want
to kind of
ignore it and to the best of their
ability pretend it didn't happen i mean
that's best exemplified by
suicide squad having a quote-unquote
sequel called the suicide squad that
relies in no way on any knowledge of the
last time they tried to do that movie
the reason the supposed continuity is
such a mess is because they're not
trying to integrate it they are seeing
what lands and if it doesn't land they
move on
and so i unless there's a major sea
change in the people handling it which
there hasn't been uh i don't see that
general approach changing but again i'll
put that one caveat that
if there are any reshoots relative to
the flash
for my money it's going to be to account
for
a different version of barrier like
there's a merging of multiple forms of
barrier and somehow it ends up looking
different i.e new actor
that is possible
that's about the only possibility left
though warner brothers
is
so screwed i cannot imagine
that they will continue to work with
ezra miller and i have to imagine they
are really annoyed with themselves
for using them
in that cameo that i mentioned uh in a
more recent thing
like
they probably wish that they could
distance themselves from ezra miller as
far as possible
but they've still got these films
already in the can
already shot
already edited
actors paid everybody paid
and in the case of the flash just
waiting on the effects work
this uh
from a sunk cost and uh potential impact
to box office is almost worst case
scenario it will be worst case if ezra
miller keeps getting in headlines in a
bad way into next year because it'll
refresh people's memories ahead of that
movie coming out at this point like
whatever impact is gonna happen to
fantastic beasts it's done they
they can't do anything at this point and
i say all this i'm not gonna say i feel
bad for warner brothers insofar as i
ever feel bad for any multi-million
dollar corporation
yeah no no pity but
like this is not a fun situation i kind
of wish i was a fly on the wall in some
of the board meetings
when they have to figure out what to do
i would be shocked
if they continue to employ ezra miller
regardless of the narrative of either of
these movies regardless of if the
character is still alive or even
positioned to be more of a main
character at the end of the third
fantastic beasts they're not gonna bring
them back and with the flash no matter
how that ends and even if they don't do
an additional reshoot to plug in another
actor
there's no way they're bringing us from
miller back after this i cannot imagine
a scenario and again that has less to do
with the severity of what they did than
the fact that it is a repeating issue i
bring this up a lot it's the reason that
gina carano was let go from star wars
but someone like rosaria dawson was not
regardless of what you think of the
specifics of the controversy around
those two performers
and their involvement with star wars and
lucasfilm
the simple fact is the controversy that
existed around rosario dawson revolved
around a single incident that was not a
repeating issue
and she also wasn't talking publicly
about it which let it fade out of the
news cycle gina carano kept showing up
in the news over and over and over and
over again
so again not about the severity of the
accusation but more about the fact that
she couldn't stop making headlines and
that's bad for image and that's what
warner brothers now has with ezra miller
oh boy
what a flippin mess
it's funny i'm not even mad
at this one i just kind of have to laugh
just
this job
the stuff i have to look into and parse
what are your thoughts on all this
whatever they are uh no personal attacks
as best you can and by personal tax i
mean like no name calling no throwing
out unfounded accusations to any of the
people who i talked about to me to other
commenters please don't do any of that
i'll delete your comment
but
other than that whatever your thoughts
are dropped something down the comments
and let's talk about it patreon is how
i'm able to uh
rework my entire schedule and take a day
to shoot this and edit it and and get it
up for early access to the patreon um
supporters so if you want to support me
there that's uh you you got to see this
about like three days early
but even if you're not able to do that
like share subscribe ton of other stuff
that i do links down in the description
to things like books twitch tick tock
twitter all that sort of thing
but um
don't worry too much about it
what i really want you to remember
is that
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
and credits i gotta shout out my top
patreon supporters so thank you very
much to zubin luthfulla barack oliver
bean melinda walters lyotha boy tt
bernabeu lax the poodle idol tracy
scrabbot vincent paul bartolucci angry
casper adam lefty taylor shane ross
robin moore shayla gourley and brendan
the rose
couldn't do it without you
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye
[Music]